hey guys i know it's been a while it's
been about a week
or more since i i last posted a youtube
video
but i'm back i was in vegas for
about five or six days i was playing the
national open
and it was my first over-the-board
tournament in about a year and a half
i played eight games total there were
nine rounds but i did take a
half point by um later in the tournament
and i had some really interesting games
which i thought i would do
kind of a youtube series and analyze
them
and hopefully share some of my
my best moves my blunders and hopefully
there's
some things that viewers can learn from
these games
and uh hopefully there's some lessons
for me to take away as well
so the first round game i played
actually one of my mods on twitch also
fellow streamer
goes by camel clutcher he has a real
name
as well i actually played camel clutcher
in a
a youtube video i posted
if people can see this the title is that
was a really weird game
this was back in 2019 i pre-moved knight
a6 on move one
this game i wanted to play something a
bit more serious
so right before the game i checked his
opening tree
loaded in his leech ass account and saw
that
he plays after knight c6 he plays d4 so
he's a scotch opening player
and i really didn't have much time to
prepare but
i figured that i would go for a sideline
bishop b4
c3 and bishop c5 i saw for the most part
he plays bishop e3
so let's get to the game um
the first few moves were expected
and i should note that a lot of people
on social media
wanted me to play a stafford which i'm
glad i didn't play in this game
because after the game my opponent told
me that
the only opening he prepared beforehand
was the stafford
which is a little bit dubious to play in
a serious slow game so knight c6 this is
a move that has been in my rapper tour
for
a long time um and against the scotch
i've uh maybe in the past i've played
bishop c5 more often here
but bishop b4 it's kind of a pet line
and
maybe to the the untrained eye or to
newer players this move
may look like a just a an unnecessary
check
and most often in the opening you don't
want to play a move like this which just
gives your opponent time to
defend the check and attack the bishop
but there is a specific purpose to play
bishop b4 here is that after c3
bishop c5 there's some argument for
black that c3
actually hinders white's development
because the knight can't
develop naturally to c3
so this is a playable line i think at
the higher levels
this line is slightly dubious for black
but it's one attempt to just get a
a game without too much theory and
that's essentially what happened
um now i was expecting bishop bishop to
e3 here
which is a main line after which i would
play bishop e6
and then there's some theory after 9
five but
my opponent played a secondary move
knight c6
and this is yeah this is still
kind of i don't want to say main line
but still theory
in the scotch opening now i should note
just for any opening
enthusiasts out there that
a more common line than the scotch is to
start with bishop's e5
and there's a main line knight takes c6
queen f6
which if we look in the opening database
there are
okay there's hundreds of thousands of
games on each us
and also in master level play now the
position that we got
uh pawn c3 is included so after knight
c6
queen f6 is not a good move
um and i'm just curious how many people
have played this on me chess
queen f6 has been played just over 200
times
uh oh by some like decently strong
players some
gm level players here um yeah this move
is
a blunder like even though it threatens
made in one it looks like black's gonna
win back the knights
white has the move knight d4 here so uh
yeah seems like a few players maybe
embarrassing
themselves with going into this
so i took back and i still had some
vague knowledge about this line
but i was on my own like pretty quickly
like after bishop d3
i had some vague memory of studying
queen h4
which i played pretty quickly and then
after queenie 2
i was i was on my own so
yeah queen h4 looks like a
maybe overly ambitious like type of move
you you would play in blitz
but the point is to exert pressure and
it's not so easy for white to actually
remove the queen
um because g3 always runs into queen h3
so i keep developing i play d6 trying to
stay flexible i wasn't sure if my knight
should go
here or here yet so opponent plays
knight d2
i play knight e7 um trying to
maybe think about later knight g6 also
preserving f5
knight f3 was played so my queen is
effectively hit
i drop back to h5 and white castles
i castle and in this position
my opponent played a very solid move
maybe not the best move but
um it was a simplifying move knight
to d4 if white doesn't play knight d4
i can potentially build a pressure with
bishop g4 and then like
coming in so i think knight g4 was
reasonable
if we turn on the engine here it
recommends
to play on the queen side one of the top
moves is bishop a6
which i think is very hard for a human
to even consider
so let's go forward with the game knight
d4 we trade
and now the game becomes very very
positional
despite the fact and opening i lunged my
queen forward we just traded queens
and i start with a5 um and this is a
typical move
i think especially for the structure
when black has a half open b
file i want to get a situation later
with the rook coming to b8 and
potentially playing a4
to create a backwards pawn on b2
so okay white just completes development
bishop e3
i attacked the pawn on b3
and now my next move
was actually a very critical move of the
game i played pawn f5
which i thought was just very intuitive
just simply because my knight my bishop
my rook
are all kind of supporting f5 and this
is
one of the main ways to fight for the
center and to try and remove the pawn on
e4
now unbeknownst to me unbeknownst is
that a word
unknown to me during this game or maybe
no maybe in the next day or this evening
like after the game was played
hikaru on his stream analyzed this full
game
and really really cringed when he saw
that i played f5 here bishop to e3 rook
v8 good move b3
f5 actually i hate
f5 what is that f5 by eric that's a
that's a
not a move that i like not a move that i
like at
all and this was probably my biggest
mistake of the game
even though in the moment i thought okay
this is a very
normal looking move it gives white some
some strong opportunities and there's
some
kind of engine lines which basically
give white an advantage after f5
one of them being bishop g5 which i'll
admit i missed during the game
where white attacks on knights and
pressures the pawn on c6
what happened the game was knight takes
f5 bishop takes f5
and in this position my opponent missed
a
really really nice in-between move
um so rather than taking back on f5
i can play bishop to c4 checking my king
and the point is that let's say i move
back
to or just play the natural move king h8
white doesn't have to take on f5 white
can take on c5
and now i'm in a kind of big predicament
if i take back
then i can just cry about my my pawns on
the queen side
and this is clearly better for whites
supported by stockfish and if i take on
e4
which is one of the lines i was thinking
about during the game
white has a really nice counter attack
even though i'm attacking the bishop on
c5 i can play rook e1
and it's very likely i'll get in the
same situation where
i'll have to take on c5 and just accept
very very sad triple pawns with white
having
just a clear positional advantage so
bishop c4 it's a hard move to kind of
wrap your mind around
where you delay taking the bishop and
you focus
on um on kind of these counter-attacking
moves
so my opponent played
after wait what happened
oh my opponent took on on c5 here
which maybe is an attempt to get a
similar line but after i take on e4
bishop c4 can now be met with bishop d5
so um okay so white played bishop e3
and basically it was just all a fair
trade and
engine will give like close to equal
here
but the thing to understand about this
position is it's very imbalanced
white does have the bishop pair but i
have some
some potential with my piece activity
and also with the structure like even
though
double pawns may seem weak on the queen
side i was able to get some
really nice harmony with the pieces and
i start with c5
and i do want to give kind of a general
rule
to positions like this where
for my side i have knight and bishop
white has a bishop hair
whenever this is a case generally
you want to place your pawns on
the opposite collar of your own bishop
and this is for two reasons of course
i don't want my pawns to get in the way
of my bishop so
in this case the pawns control the dark
squares my bishop controls the light
squares
this is one way to kind of maximize
square control
the other reason for putting the pawns
on dark squares is to restrict
white's dark sword bishop because i
don't have a dark squared bishop of my
own i really really want to be careful
that dark squares don't get weak
in my territory and in this case the the
position is actually really solid
and the game continues rook d1
i play king h8 this was kind of a
flexible move
i was anticipating maybe a bishop coming
to c4
so i figured my king would eventually
move to h8
and i can i can stay flexible
f3 was played bishop g6
rookie one and now i play a4 so this is
one of the
the thematic breaks in the position it
was really hard for white to stop this
move
a4 um is a hard move to play because b3
is always a
target and my idea is just to weaken
the queen side structure so white took
um i don't think there's too many other
options because i am threatening the
sequence of
bishop c2 and then taking and then
winning upon
maybe starting with taking in bishop c2
so
white took i went back the pawn
and then we get to a situation okay i
put my rook
on well i thought is a more useful
central file
uh white plays rook b2 i play bishop c6
bishop d2 and in this position
i probably took the longest think of the
game
now of course i i started just
trying to search for candidate moves and
my initial thought was to play
knight c8 with idea of playing knight b6
to block the b-file attack the bishop
trade a pair of rooks
um but then i realized if i played
knight c8
white can take on e8 and then
play bishop f7 and this is kind of a
funny line
but more funny in white's favor because
after a move like rook cafe trying to
get the bishop out of here
and trying to continue with the plan of
knight b6
white has a really nice kind of
counter-attack
rook b8 leaving the bishop on f7 i can't
take it
and i was calculating this position
during the game and realized
i could just get stuck because there's
ideas of bishop e6
if i play a move like g6
i think in itself is already a blunder
because bishop e6 there's also ideas of
bishop h6 coming in
so it's very easy for the pieces to get
stuck here
for black and instead of
knight c8 i went ahead and played knight
d5
now the risk to this move is i do allow
an obstacle bishop ending if um
if white does decide let's say to take
take
take on d5 i take back i think white
would have like reasonable drawing
chances here
but i was willing to play this play this
position out for a win
because there's a clear idea of rook
eight going after they two pawn
and i think only black can uh uh
can play for a win from here so it would
have been a
a safe choice for me and after the game
my opponent told me that he didn't want
to suffer in that ending
and it's a hard decision for white
especially when you have the bishop pair
uh to to make the commitment to trade it
off and kind of just accept a worse
position
so i can't blame light for first trading
on e8
and then avoiding the trade on d5 and
playing king f2
um now in hindsight as we're going to
see for the rest of the game
white suffered a lot more given i was
able to keep my knight on the board
so it probably would have been better
for white to take
but uh because white didn't take we're
gonna see how
um how the bishop knight combination
can overpower the bishop hair
so i went ahead played knight b6 hit the
bishop
i played bishop d3 which might be
another inaccuracy
just because it it leaves the pawn a bit
weaker on a2
bishop b3 was probably preferable oh
thanks for some
thanks for who's that ghost manser just
subscribed
i don't think i'm streaming no i'm not
streaming
i'm using obs um
so the record button is next to the
start streaming button
but uh i appreciate the sub
what was i saying yeah bishop d3
another uh small inaccuracy because
after
rook eight um this pawn is
uh is just a clear target
bishop g5 was played and i go after a2
so yeah so i start with h6
i play g5 i win the pawn
and in this moment i was actually half
expecting my opponent to blunder
but uh i've only just played the played
the best move right away just takes on
e2
i was hoping for a bishop c2 which might
seem like a natural looking move
like okay white's down the pawn so white
wants to keep uses on the board
um so i'll leave this for the viewers
this is black to move and
win material by force
so if you don't see it feel free to
pause the video but the move is
bishop c4 which i thought was a kind of
a nifty way of
removing the guard and exploiting the
potential pin
along the second rank so if white plays
this
king g7 the bishop's gonna be lost
there's no way to defend it rookie seven
one last check
and white's losing material and then the
other line if rook d2
now the rook's not defended the bishop
pinned to the rook
i can play bishop b3 and win material
like this
so white didn't fall for that we trade
on a2
and now it was a question of converting
this position i have five pawns
white has four pawns but white has a
bishop pair
and in the moment i thought there's
there's probably decent chances for like
to draw
i was still okay going into this because
i'm the only one playing for a win
and uh i have very kind of easy play
going forward of course my king wants to
come in
my knight wants to centralize and in the
meantime
it's hard for white to target any
weaknesses in my position
because this structure is very solid my
kings on kingside pawns are always
defended
so okay king e3 was played i
walked my king in we trained on g5
i brought the bishop back trying to be
patient
and i realized white was just waiting
here like just moving the bishop back
so it's kind of what white has to do in
this position just wait
and see what black is up to um i play
bishop f5
if we do trade the light squared bishops
then it would be a bit easier to make
progress
because then my knight can come in and
wreak havoc on the king's side so
white made the correct decision
preserving the light squared bishop
i play knight d5 forcing king d2
and now knight f4 now this is another
move
i have to calculate of course because i
am allowing
bishop takes on f4
but it was pretty straightforward to see
that the resulting
end game would be winning for black
because i have the clear plan of
bringing the king to h4
forcing either the bishop or the white
king
to just be sad on f1
i down to the pawn i should know g4 is
never possible here
i guess it is possible but it's not good
because on passant
um would save the day for me um
so if we got a situation let's imagine
like king e1
king g5 king f2 king h4 um
the the winning plan for black would
just be playing
d5 d4 and making a pass pawn
and if you're if you're not like
entirely understanding how black is
winning this uh
feel free to analyze with the engine um
i can even encourage people to like play
it out against engine
if you go to the link to the study go to
this position
and do continue from here uh
um can i do it right now i could
okay let's let's show how to win this uh
from position we'll play blitz
it's gonna be really embarrassing if i
don't win this
um let's just do like three two
i'll play stockfish level eight
i'll be back
okay so white plays bishop c4
okay so the way to win this is to be
very very patient uh of course i want to
play this
so i probably want to start with c6
i know it's a little bit committal
fixing the pawn on the light square
i have to do this
no let's start with bishop c8 because
white just has to play a waiting game i
want to prepare
um pushing d5 so i'll play this
okay now i
ready to to push oh
c4 okay that doesn't scare me
i'm gonna move the bishop back and then
go for c6d5
okay c6
and now d5 so my bishop has some x-ray
vision
so i'm getting the two connected past
juicers as hikaru would say now the
question is how do i make progress
uh because i don't want to push and lose
my bishop so i might actually have to
move back this way
and then walk in with my king um
yeah that's probably that's probably the
way to go
so my king served its purpose and now
let's move into the center
okay with trading
i just want to play king d4 uh i have to
be careful of the f pawn
maybe this move first
and now this move okay ready to play
this
oh that's kind of annoying
and stockfish is so tricky
wait what is this bishop a2
measure of a2 c4 let's prevent
light from moving forward now play this
move
okay now i'm ready to just charge with
the c pawn
stockfish is very good at putting up
resistance though
it's actually kind of annoying oh
f6 is a thread okay so let's play this
wait a minute i get tricked
i have this move
i think this is still okay then bishop
e6
what is this
i have this move f6
wow
this is crazy if i'm not winning this c3
king here
maybe bishop here but no again f6
oh i have c okay let's start with c3
king 2 bishop's e4
oh no
wait i have this move i think it's okay
oh no ah
oh it's drawing me what is it wait i'm
this move no
[Music]
i thought it was gonna be an easy win
how did it draw me
wait
okay it's completely winning here i just
had to be careful
with a thing so c4 is a blunder
very explosive blunder
anyway okay let me show how i won in the
game
um i would hope that if i got this end
game
hell i go back
if i got this end game in the tournament
game i would figure out how to win
anyway hopefully that's uh an
instructive like training method for
people if you want to work on your end
games
you can play it out against stockfish
like especially winning positions
sometimes shows you where the tricks and
traps can lie
for the the player on the worst side
um we didn't go into this line white
didn't take on
on f4 i played bishop f1 reserving the
bishop here
and then then i found kind of a cool
maneuver
um which involved bringing my knight
to a square
that controlled c4 and the point is i
just wanted to trade
light squared bishops um okay of course
stockfish likes black
i'm up a pawn but still takes work to
win
and in this case it's hard for
it's hard for white to avoid the trade
why play that f4 which actually made my
life a bit easier
um what probably should have been played
it's a funny line but bishop b5
bishop c4 and then bishop wait a minute
oh bishop d7 can't be played
i was thinking bishop d7 apparently i
was analyzing this earlier this is hangs
of bishop
i was thinking after bishop f1 bishop h3
i guess the bishop can't make its way to
h3
tonight is useful on on b6 controlling
these two squares so the bishop can't
walk its way around
okay so maybe f4 was a decent try
but after bishop c4 we trade
trade now it's knight in three against
bishop in two but i have a three on one
majority
um and here we're going to see the power
of the knight
in the end game usually in
wide open positions the bishop is the
one who prospers
but the the advantage that the knight
has over the bishop
is the fact that it can target any
square on the chessboard
the bishop is limited to just the square
that or the color square that it's on so
it can only control dark squares
so in this position like there's no way
for the bishop to defend
on on the light square and um
yeah my knight can continually hop
around
uh king d7 so hitting the bishop
still threatening the pawn i win the
pawn
and it looks like my knight is almost
trapped here
but thankfully i do have an escape route
via f2
and then d1 and then eventually coming
back around
so at this point i i knew it was winning
but still took some some more dancing
with the knights
and thankfully my king was was very
clutch just
defending all the pawns and
yeah the the final winning maneuver was
to bring my knight
to over defend the d-pawn to then allow
my king to walk up
and target the sea pawn which
did eventually happen i was okay losing
my c7 pawn
got my knight in and white resigned in
this position
so i feel like this is a game that
people don't usually see me play
like a sort of very positional grinding
end game
i know when i stream
blitz and bullet online i like to play
in the the dubious aggressive gambit
style
but in slower games this is actually uh
a fun style to play where i try and keep
control the whole time
try and make use of the solo positional
advantages
and after the game we talked a bit we
analyzed a bit
and we concluded that white didn't make
any
serious blunders it was more
just making a bunch of subtle
inaccuracies
and probably the biggest missed
opportunity for white was
when i played that five um allowing this
whole kind of
tactical sequence if uh if white managed
to find the stockfish line
by taking and then throwing in this
bishop c4 move
but hopefully this is a nice example of
how to
uh how to try and outplay the opponent
especially when they have the bishop
hair
as bishop bishop pairs can be scary but
there's other factors that can influence
who's better in in the position
so anyway if you have questions or
comments
leave them below uh this was the first
round
out of nine total rounds um
so i'll be making recap videos for every
game
um and i'll leave a link to
the the study and stay tuned for the
next video
thanks for watching